hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you
oh
[Music]
assalamu alaikum
how are you guys doing many of you will
know that Russell Brand now has made the
news and people are accusing him of some
very easiest crimes and whereas I don't
really want to speak about those
allegations or get into that to be
honest with you I do want to make a
point which I think is applicable and
relevant and poignant
and pertinent for the modern day which
is the following is that in Islam we
have a concept called okay which is an
Islamic marriage this is the contract of
Islamic marriage this will come relevant
in a second or the reason why I'm
telling you this will become uh relevant
in a second now this concept of Nika
for all intents and purposes actually it
solves a lot of the problems which are
happening nowadays relating to sexual
assault allegations and so on well it
leads to a great extent it facilitates
some kind of uh I would say alleviation
of the problem why because when Anika
actually takes place in Islam it's a
very simple process by the way where the
man of the woman get married
and there are two witnesses and then
consent is given and taken in in that
context and is documented now this
process although it could take
technically speaking technically it
takes about three to five minutes and it
can be done in three to five minutes it
actually serves the purpose not just the
spiritual purpose of making the Mata
holy in front of God but it actually
serves a practical functionality which
is that it would at least on paper it
should at least on paper
uh alleviate some of these issues
because if consent is given and uh it's
known that in this after that both
become Halal for one another will both
become legitimately uh or intercourse
becomes a legitimate course of action
then I would say if someone were to say
that this was an unwanted sexual
attention in certain contexts then I
would say legally it would probably make
sense in most countries laws that the
defense would be stronger if the person
has consent being given in front of two
people uh that's one thing I want to
bring to the table because Islam is a
solution for a lot of these issues you
see it's not just a spiritual solution
but we will say it's a practical
solution so although I don't want to
speak about the specific case of Russell
Brand Visa V what's going on with him uh
you know these allegations and so on I
don't want to speak about that because
I'm not really fully aware of what's
going on but what I do want to say is
that if someone conducts their business
in the manner that Islam prescribed then
the matter becomes much more
professional and less problems are
attached to such things
what I want to react to today in fact is
something completely different which is
one of the only interviews I've seen
Russell Brand speak about Islam and
about Muslim people and there are two
kind of time stamps in particular which
I looked at in his discussion with some
errors which I think are pertinent so
let's look at the first one and react to
it together right like and suicide
bombing so it's just Aesthetics really
no it's not suicide bombing no it looks
bad a drone bombing it's not just
Aesthetics it's not just Aesthetics
because suicidal people are undeterable
so jihadists are undeterable If part if
the best thing that can happen in an
operation is that you die while
conducting it you are the perfect weapon
I have to hammer this home when you're
talking about the possibility like of
something like nuclear terrorism or
biological terrorism that you know where
someone tries to weaponize smallpox I'm
still 100 million people just mentioned
that so the nuclear terrorism he's not
hypothetical it already happened 50
years ago
secularism I won't call that nuclear
terrorism or nuclear I don't know there
was certainly a first year in Nagasaki
That Base semantics wouldn't be your
primary concern what should we call that
thing wow my teeth it's reasonable to
ask well how the so this is very
very interesting here you see I think
this was a it was actually a Priceless
interaction the back and forth and in my
view Russell Brand definitely had the
upper hand now first and foremost we
could talk about suicide bombing and
we'll talk about the the numbers of
people Muslim people that actually
believe in this legitimacy we can talk
about that on a mass level or on a uh
even on a scholarly level how many
people have given that legitimacy in
fact this is not the rule but the
exception within the Islamic Paradigm
both doctrinally or you can say
theologically Jewish prudentially as
well as sociologically in terms of what
Muslim people will believe is legitimate
or not legitimate action that's one
thing anyway that's a conversation we
can have another day but the point being
made here by Russell Brand is actually a
very powerful point and notice the
reluctance of Sam Harris to take
ownership of the fact that I mean
Hiroshima Nagasaki the two most
devastating and we're talking about two
of the most devastating uh detonations
that have taken place probably in human
history okay and that was detonated by a
country who as he mentioned is is got a
secular ethic it's it's constitutions uh
or the constitution of America and the
founding the the documents all of them
are secular documents uh underwritten by
liberalism social contractarianism and
so on and so forth It's a liberal
democracy for intents and purposes yet
they were the ones responsible for this
kind of thing notice his reluctance to
refer to that as terrorism why not
and this shows you the double standard
here it shows you the double standard it
shows you the weakness of the argument
so I commend actually Russell Brand on
this instant for making this point and
saying what he said here it was a and
his right to point out in the beginning
in fact that this is just Aesthetics
especially considering uh what he
mentions in the moral landscape the Sam
Harris has written a book called the
moral landscape
obviously he talks about
consequentialism he believes a kind of
moral philosophy called consequentialism
which by the way there's no way on an
atheistic or naturalistic Paradigm to
actually prove that consequentialism is
true on an objective level that's one
thing anyway so that does become about
Aesthetics it comes about what is and he
mentions this himself is fetishized in
the imagination of the western uh person
the average Muslim person so that's one
thing the other thing I want to respond
to or react to is another aspect of this
podcast so let's hear that bit and then
come back and respond in kind I think
that these kind of uh sort of
theoretical tablosed are used to create
a false hierarchy and a moral
superiority by a dominant culture that
subsequently uses thinking of this of
this nature to underwrite the modern day
colonization and subjugation of these
people on a massive scale as barbaric
and disgusting as 911 was a daily 9 11
since then so that a state system can
perpetuate itself using rationalism
using comfortable means of executions
that Glide slyly by all white in the sky
is no better or than the 911 news it is
better too it is it is better so we can
talk so you're invoking many things here
which we should treat systematically
things like collateral damage so you you
drop I don't even like that language
no it's a euphemism but that's that's
the word we use to talk about unintended
people getting killed by bombs but what
is that like when 87 of drone strikes
was a result in uh the data here are
hard to get our hands around as well
highly politicized yes you see whenever
the the argument is being made against
the objective fact of secular violence
State violence which has taken place in
the 20th and 21st century on a scale
that human history hasn't succeed before
that human history forget about
religious uh States or whatever
Theocratic States we're talking about
human history has never seen before you
notice that he wants to complicate the
situation notice that Sam Harris is
trying his best to try and muddy the
waters
and I I have to respect and give uh you
know props to uh Russell Brand actually
for making these distinctions and it
seems like throughout the interview he
was very careful not to fall into what
would be seen as an orientalist
discourse you have to give him credit
for that I think he did go to the school
of Oriental and African studies and done
some kind of postgraduate there one of
the key readings that they would read is
like you know Edward sides orientalism
or something like that where the power
structures have been discussed and it is
relevant and it's actually very useful
because then he's not he's not easily
he's not gullible and naive to these
kinds of discourses which are intended
to preach to the converted or to
preacher Choir in one way or another the
thing is Sam Harris himself cannot
substantiate why morals uh should be one
way or not not another on on naturalism
or Atheism in the first instance and in
fact on his deterministic worldview he
shouldn't even be holding those
perpetrators responsible for anything
because a suicide bomber is no different
from any kind of bomber uh according to
his world view he's written a book on
Free Will and determinism and he
believes that there is no such thing as
a Libertarian free will or a
compatibilistic free will so in other
words people are not in charge of their
Emotions free will is full intents and
purposes an illusion so if you if you
look at a package of Sam Harris's
um ethics and moralities you'll find
that the way he puts the case really is
is a very weak way and is
self-contradictory when you compare all
of the different things that he believes
in but having said all of this Sam
Harris would never
discuss Islam with Muslim people have
you ever seen Sam Harris discuss Islam
with Muslim people in fact I've
challenged him many times I'm not even
going to waste my breath challenging him
again he's become quite irrelevant
actually and a weak opponent he would
probably be and he tried to block me on
Twitter some time ago when I challenged
him he made him either back and forth
and he ran away he scurried along and
put his tail between his legs but I have
to commend Russell Brand on this
interaction and I hope it was useful to
you guys and beneficial as well
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
Jannah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale